foreign
[Music]
we play E4 and of course we play our
favorite allop and Sicilian let's see
how the elephant holds up at a very high
level at a 2000 plus level Knight F6 as
I said at this level we're essentially
exclusively facing the two main
responses to the elephant the first of
which is D5 we face that move a lot we
haven't faced Knight F6 as much so this
is a great opportunity for us to review
some of the theory of this line and for
me to show some new exciting analysis so
after Knight D5 we already kind of need
to get into the weeds because there are
essentially two fundamentally different
ways of playing the alapan the first is
the more traditional approach which is
which is to play D4 in this position
this is what you might have seen then
black plays Pawn takes D4 and notice
that in that resulting position white
doesn't have to recapture on D4 because
D takes C3 is not a threat the queen
x-rays the Knight so the main line is D4
Pawn takes D4 and then actually Knight
F3 is a very important inclusion but
recently elephant experts have embarked
on a fundamentally different approach a
more exciting approach that leads to far
more tactical positions rather than
playing D4 it is worth starting with the
move Knight F3 in many cases this
transposes to the main line generally
black plays Knight C6 then you might
think that white has to play D4 black
plays Pawn takes pawn and we have
ourselves the main line of the elephant
but after Knight C6 there is a second
approach and this is the approach I'd
like to introduce you to in this game
assuming that our opponent plays Knight
C6 which is not a given black can also
play D6 black can also play E6 and those
are the three main moves Knight C6 is on
the board does anybody know what move
I'm implying this may seem
okay depending on how you look at this
move it may seem very natural but upon
closer examination this move may seem to
be a serious positional mistake I'm
talking of course about Bishop to C4 we
bring our Bishop out straight away we
hit the Knight on D5 and we're
essentially forcing the Knight to move
back to B6 or black can also support the
Knight with E6 which is a very popular
move I don't think it's a very good line
for black
I am really hoping to see E6 I think
those positions are really really fun to
play for white but so are the main lines
after Knight to B6 in which case we drop
our Bishop back to B3 why did I say that
this may seem like a serious positional
mistake well we're actually encouraging
black to play a very scary looking move
here our opponent didn't play it and
that's the move C4 and C4 is scary
because if we then play D4 at any later
Point black and on passant and break up
are punch in so it may seem like we're
gonna end up losing our E5 pawn and I'll
show you some of the theory after C4
based on the new uh Spindler chessable
course as well as the call of fun Bible
and those lines are incredibly
fascinating what you will see is that we
often end up sacrificing the E5 pawn and
we go for Rapid Fire play on The Queen
side and in the center and I think this
line has breathed a lot of new life into
the elephant so some exciting stuff
coming up after this game but D5 is the
traditional Main Line This is how people
used to play this exclusively uh you
know 15 20 years ago and here we need to
not miss the opportunity to take on
passant if we don't take on black gets
like an ideal setup by bringing their
Bishop out to G4 so without out question
we need to take on person and keep the
diagonal for this bishop open
and now we need to quickly develop our
pieces you may
attracted to the possibility of the
immediate D4 but we're not really aiming
to play a quick D4 that's not the point
of this particular line the point of
this line is to quickly develop your
pieces and actually go after the B6
Knight and you might say go after the B6
Knight how on Earth is that possible
well there is a very important idea and
by carrying it out you're lighting the
fire on the queen side but first first
things first we need to get our King out
of the center
and you need to realize that Bishop G4
is an incredibly common blunder in this
position it walks right into the common
tactic Bishop takes F7 check I've won
countless games like that even against
other GMS and after King takes F7 it's
the classic Knight G5 check we pick up
the bishop with interest Bishop B6 is
the main line and this is where things
get really interesting traditionally the
main line has always been Knight A3 and
if you've watched the allop and speedrun
videos to date you will know that Knight
A3 is a very classic developing move
because the Knight aims directly for B5
so that's what people used to play all
the time and then recently a new idea
has taken the elephant by storm here's
what it involves first of all we trade
Bishops on E6 and we do that in order to
buy ourselves a couple of Tempe what
does that mean well we're making it
difficult for black to develop his King
side right black would love to play E6
on the next move but he can he's got to
move the queen away and that cost
the bishop but that's two more Tempe and
we use these Tempe to develop rapid play
on The Queen side who can tell me what
idea I've been employing for a while now
it's it's not D4 and D4 is again the
traditional way to play we go after
Black's night on B6 with the move A4
an idea that you should be familiar with
because it's universally applied in many
different types of positions we're
shoving this Pawn down to A5
you might look at this and say well I
don't get how this is dangerous right
the move A5 is just a one move thread
and the Knight has plenty of retreating
squares hopefully the course of the game
will reveal why A5 is actually a
dangerous idea and it's not because the
Knight on B6 is somehow in trouble it's
because we're trying to push this Pawn
all the way up to A6 and create
long-term weaknesses for black on the
queen side in particular some of the
light squares are going to become weak
and believe it or not the pawn on A7 is
going to become a long-term weakness
once it is fixed in place by our Pawn on
A6 of course if black plays A5 here
which is a legitimate move then the
Knight on B6 loses its Defender black
creates a gaping weakness on B5 which we
can immediately occupy with our Knight
and at the right moment we will play D4
and blast open the center and there
might be hell to pay for black if he
makes too many weaknesses on the queen
side
yeah of course rookie one is a move that
most of you are going to be tempted to
play but remember the sort of philosophy
behind this line it's actually a good
thing that the queen is on E6 it's
making it difficult for black to get the
king side pieces out so rookie one would
actually help Black by forcing the queen
back to D7 we don't want to play rookie
one unless there's a compelling reason
to do so
very instructive Point by the way right
you can see how at this level these
tempting looking moves are actually
often bad Queen D7 so our opponent is
abiding by the sort of clear strategy of
gang side development that means we have
no time to waste we need to continue our
Queen side campaign with A5 and this is
still Theory Queen D7 is believe the
main line and don't worry we we are
gonna play D4 we're just waiting for the
perfect opportunity to do that
Knight T5 okay so we need to complete
the picture on the queen side what we do
not want to allow is we don't want to
allow black to play A6 uh themselves
because then our Pawn on A5 becomes a
very serious liability it's a liability
because well because the Knight on C6
aims at the pawn and we don't want black
to freeze the queen side before we've
done our job we want to freeze the queen
side on our terms
on our terms which means we want to
throw in the move A6 and as I've
explained we're trying to induce the
move B6 and it may not seem like the
weak light squares on the queen side are
accessible because we don't have a light
squared Bishop anymore that Bishop got
traded for its counterpart on E6 but
there is a piece called a queen and
queens also move diagonally so the queen
is going to be ultimately the vehicle
that we're going to use to try to
exploit the queen side light Square
weaknesses
I'm anticipating the move B6 if black
doesn't play B6 then we will take on B7
and shatter Black's entire Queen side if
black plays B takes A6 the same thing
applies and black merely invites our
Rook onto a Super Active Square B6 is
played now again we need to be very
accurate because if we fall asleep then
black is going to play E6 and Bishop E7
and these squares look very nice but we
we actually need to develop the
Machinery in order to exploit them in
particular we need to combine positional
play on The Queen side with a general
approach that involves making it as
difficult as possible for black to
develop uh his Bishop right we want
black to remain Frozen in place on the
king side because it's going to make it
difficult for black to protect some of
these weak squares and the weak A7 upon
on the queen side this means that it's
the perfect opportunity for us to strike
in the center with the move d4
and this might be the last opportunity
that we're gonna get so we need to jump
on the opportunity train before it's
left the station D4
opening up the center and not forcing
black to take on D4 black I guess can
also play the move E6 here we'll cross
that bridge if we get there
but the point and hopefully you're
starting to form a clearer picture of
what it is we're trying to accomplish
here if black takes on D4 which is what
most people will play then we take back
with the Knight and if black takes we
take back with our Queen what is our
Queen on D4 going to be doing well first
of all it's in the center it's supported
by a C3 Pawn but most importantly it's
aiming at the G7 Pawn so it would have
made it very hard for black to bring his
Bishop out of f8 E6 is on the board I'm
impressed with the way that our opponent
has handled the opening let me think
about this for a second I don't remember
what the theoretical move is here I have
to think about this
so I think it might be Knight A3
I think it might be Knight A3 but I'm
not totally sure so I need a moment to
think here it's I mean C4 C4 is a very
tempting move but the problem with C4 is
that it opens up new prospects for black
snide it allows Knight D to B4 so I
really don't like C4 our Pawn chain and
the center falls apart
hey Hannah
okay there's also 95 oh it is 95 I think
the move is actually 95 here I suddenly
remembered that I'm pretty sure the move
is 95. and 95 is a hard move to explain
so assuming I have this right I'm going
to wait until after the game to kind of
fully flesh out the motivation behind
95. long story short we're inviting a
night trade and we're changing the the
nature of the pawn structure right once
the pawn repositions to E5 the pawn
structure changes completely from a
potential iqp structure to a structure
that arises in various allopin lines
with that pawn lording over Black's
position from E5 and you should sort of
understand why the pawn on E5 is so
powerful because it's controlling two
very important squares F6 and D6 black
would love to bring the dark squared
Bishop to F6 ultimately
and black would love to have the F6
Square for the night in the event that
white plays C4 for example
so after the trade of knights the D file
opens and white being the more active
side with better placed pawns and more
space is more well positioned to exploit
the opening up of the D file there's
also a very important idea without which
this approach wouldn't really work which
is that after the trade on E5 which has
just happened I'm assuming our opponent
will play Bishop B7 who can tell me and
having knowledge of typical elephant
ideas really helps what's a very typical
way to meet Bishop E7 in these types of
positions this should be largely
automatic for you this type of move
it's it's Queen G4 it's Queen D1 to G4 I
know it's funny that we haven't brought
our minor pieces out this is Ultimate
modern chess but black can't punish us
for that because our King is very very
safe Queen G4 is super super strong
because after black castles we can bring
our Bishop out to H6 and that is the
Crux of why E5 is so strong Bishop F6 in
that resulting position would not have
been possible so black loses the
exchange but all of that is a moot point
because black delays the move Bishop B7
and instead plays Rook d8 let's think
about what our priorities are in this
position so first of all we should not
forget about the long-term weakness of
the A7 pawn and the best way that we
have to exploit that is ultimately to
get the Knight around to B5 what would
the Knight on B5 be doing well obviously
it would be pressuring the A7 pawn and
keeping Black's Queen at Bay so one idea
is to immediately play the move Knight
to A3 and develop our Knight also the
Knight could potentially access the D6
Square I understand that there's the
bishop here but maybe the circumstances
will change there are other candidate
moves there is the move Bishop G5 which
I don't like because it invites a bishop
trade and I think our dark Squad Bishop
is a very important asset here which
could drop uh pay a visit to H6 such as
in the line that we were just talking
about so between those two developing
moves I like Knight A3 but there's a
third type of move that we could play we
could preemptively move our Queen either
to F3 or even immediately to G4 in order
to make it as difficult as possible for
black to bring his Bishop out to E7
Queen G4 would walk into the rather
annoying move H5 and if you drop the
queen back to G3 blackened keeps shoving
the pawn down the board with H4 so I'm
not convinced that that favors White
so from that perspective I like to move
Knight A3
but I like both of these moves 9a3 and
queen G4 both have their pluses and
minuses
let me think about this for a second
which of these do we want to choose
I think
I think we should play Knight A3 it just
seems to me that Knight A3 is the more
flexible approach to the position
because we don't know exactly where this
queen is going to belong we can always
play Queen G4 nobody's going to be
taking that move away from us
so let's start by bringing the Knight
onto a square where it is ready at a
moment's notice to to drop into B5 and
we want that ability because should the
black queen move away from the seventh
rank then Knight B5 is a potentially
devastating move right if black loses A7
even if it's the middle game that pawn
on A6 is going to decide the game and
that's by the way why we're leaving The
Rook on A1 that may seem like a lame
Rook but oftentimes you want to leave it
there for the occasion in which you take
on A7 and then you want that pawn to be
supported
so yeah so many of you are suggesting
the move B5 here
oh B5 true it stops us from playing
Knight B5 but it also adds further
strain to the the queen side right
because then the Knight is automatically
pressuring the B5 Pawn leaving the queen
rather passive in response to that move
I like the look of Queen G4 okay Bishop
E7 virtually forces our hand other than
Queen G4 we could still play Queen F3
but if we're bringing the queen out and
we might as well use it to induce some
weaknesses on the king side Queen G4 is
an automatic move
and you can see that we're starting to
squeeze black right castles Bishop H6
loses the exchange and if we can force
black to to introduce kingside
weaknesses then black will have
weaknesses on both sides of the board
and we're gonna keep overextending black
by trying to get the Knight to B5 and in
response to G6 Bishop H6 is a classic
reaction that prevents black from
castling we've got a big initiative here
now things that we need to be careful
about obviously the E5 Pawn has been
left without a Defender and we need to
keep keep an eye on it
we of course need to keep an eye on our
A6 Pawn watch out for moves like Knight
back to C7 stuff like that
and other than that our position is very
easy to play We also should not get
fixated on the prospect of Knight B5
because in some situations if the dark
squared Bishops are traded as I pointed
out earlier Knight C4 Knight D6 might be
a more worthwhile maneuver for the night
another concept to keep in mind is the
move C4 C4 is a move that we could play
on demand and the point of C4 would be
not only to chase the Knight away from
D5 but to open up the possibility of
Knight to B5 of course after C4 the
knight's gonna drop back to C7 that's
what we have to be very careful about
because then A6 is hanging and we can't
really go Knight B5 because black has
two eyes on that square
so notice how on our opponent's turn I'm
talking about more General ideas this is
the sort of classic Uh Russian School of
Chess recommendation I think Alexander
kotov who wrote How to Think Like A
Grandmaster one of the sort of seminal
texts of the 20th century he advocated
for this approach where you use your
turn to calculate concrete variations
and when your opponent is taking a while
to think you're essentially developing
conceptual wisdom about the position
you're shuffling through typical ideas
you're making mental notes to yourself
like this is when I need to be careful
about this is what I need to look for
and in that way you're using every
second effectively because on your
opponent's turn there's a lot of
uncertainty and your opponent has a lot
of options so unless you are fully
anticipating a certain response it
actually makes sense to abide by that
advice I think
foreign
there's a lot to calculate and you
really need to use every second to
calculate a certain variation
or you're in time pressure in that case
it's all calculation
okay Bishop f8 back oh that is a juicy
move that is a clear sign that our
opponent is in full back pedal mode
now
well okay how are we going to get to
Black's position first things first
there's a crazy tactical sequence that
I'm trying to puzzle out the move Rook
D1 comes to my mind immediately as a way
to pin the queen and to threaten C4 but
if you look carefully at the move Rook
D1 black could then drop the Knight back
to F6
and if we take the Knight then our Rooks
are not coordinated so Queen takes D1 is
checkmate but if we look further after
Rook D1 Knight F6 Rook takes Queen
Knight takes Queen our back rank is weak
so we can't take on A7 but what we can
do is trade Rooks on d8 finally our
Knight gets into B5 and the game is over
because black loses A7 as a result so
Rook D1 looks very very juicy it does in
fact threaten the move C4 not because C4
wins the Knight it doesn't but because
it forces the aforementioned transition
to a winning end game
okay I need to think about this a little
bit more because Bishop G5 is the second
candidate move I like Bishop G5 just as
much
I like Bishop G5 just as much I don't
really see the downside of Bishop to G5
I guess the only thing we'd have to be
careful about is F6 and as weakening as
the move F6 is it buys black at Tempo
and I'm not sure that I want to part
ways with even a single Tempo I also
don't want to part ways with the E5 pawn
and Bishop G5 F6 essentially encourages
us to give that pawn away I don't like
that as much because the pawn is what's
exerting the kind of vice-like grip on
Black's position so as crazy as it
sounds I'm actually going to not play
the tempo move which I think a lot of
you would kind of play automatically
right Bishop G5 partially also because I
want to maintain contact with the G7
Pawn
and I want to make sure the black is not
getting that Bishop out anytime soon oh
it's weird but Bishop G5 is not going
anywhere right you can really play this
move now
and now I think it would be an even
better idea because F6 is no longer as
dangerous of a response and the reason
why let's say we play Bishop G5 which we
will black will play F6 we play e takes
F6 G takes F6 we have a check on H5 and
the chief difference is that black
cannot block that check on F7 with the
queen right because by Shifting the
queen to C6 black has lost contact with
the F7 Square does that make sense so
now the look of Bishop G5 or Bishop G5
looks a lot more attractive to me than
it did on the previous move
if Bishop E7 then of course we take the
bishop I think or we play C4 which is a
move that has been you know that we've
kept in mind for a long time I think C4
might win the game after Bishop E7
now could I have played C4 here
absolutely I could have played C4 here
but the Knight would have dropped back
to C7 we would have traded Rooks and
then we would have delivered a check on
G5 and then we would have brought the
other Rook Diddy one and actually
probably that would be that would have
been an even better idea somehow I
didn't pay attention to the power of C4
yeah C4 might have just ended the game
but maybe not maybe maybe it would have
allowed the Knight to sort of defend
some of these key light squares I don't
know Bishop G5 is is I'm sure going to
be good enough to win the game
yeah C4 would have been very very
explosive but so is this move and we can
play C4 on the next move it's not going
anywhere
C4 is not going anywhere at all
but yeah I'm a little bit bummed I
didn't play it right away
but anyways our opponent is down to six
and a half minutes
you can just sense how much pressure
black is under because all three sides
of the board the Queen side the center
and the King side belong to us we're in
charge
on all three sides and when that is the
case you can essentially rest assured
that you know you're probably going to
win the game unless you do something
really dumb
what is actually the point of Bishop G5
well largely it's to coordinate the
Rooks and why is it important to
coordinate the Rooks because after we
play C4 we want to be able to trade
Rogues and then bring the other Rook to
D1 immediately in order to grab control
of that open default but all of that's a
moot point because F6 has been played
and this fundamentally changes the
character of The Struggle from
positional to now completely tactical
now don't give a check on H5 prematurely
because that walks into G6 and we lose a
piece
at this point we need to transform our
advantage the E5 Pawn has been the pride
of our position for so long but now we
transform our advantage from that pawn
being on E5 to the black king being in
Mortal Danger
so you have to be ready and willing at a
moment's notice to give away something
that you're proud of and something that
you're hanging your hat on if you can
understand
that you know you're transitioning the
character of the advantage from one
thing to another from positional to
Tactical from domination over squares to
a direct attack against the King which
is the case here
does that hopefully that concept makes
sense and the higher rated you are the
more flexible you have to be in terms of
changing your advantage from one thing
to another okay now what was the
critical move that wasn't as good with
the queen being on D7 it was a check on
H5 we forced the black king out into the
open and I made this move without any
calculation because there's no risk
there's zero risk attached to the move
Queen H5 check we know for a fact that
it's not going to make our position any
worse and so I made it largely without
calculation even though maybe just
Bishop H4 would have been just as good
if not better because now it occurs to
me that the F6 Pawn is well protected
and after Bishop H4 we have to reckon
with Knight F4 which I completely missed
but I don't think it's an issue so let
me think about this for a second the
move C4
the move C4 even here is very
interesting
because after the trade on G5 the King
has to drop back to E8
and then we don't even have to take the
Knight immediately we could even pay a
visit to the B5 square with our Knight
that looks really juicy
we could also Play Bishop H4 but then
there is this move Knight F4 and it's a
little bit Troublesome I will confess
that was a very careless Moment by me
so maybe C4 is not such a bad idea after
all
c4f takes G5 Queen takes G5 King E8
okay then maybe we play Knight to B5
okay let me I'm just trying to make
sense of that resulting position
and to really understand if it's totally
winning or if it's more complicated than
it seems I I think it's totally winning
my intuition is screaming to play the
move C4 and I'll flesh this out more
after the game but I just have a feeling
that Now's the Time To Play C4 again
Bishop H4 I was worried about Knight to
F4 and there are some tactics there with
Bishop takes F6 check King takes F6 and
then Queen H4 check the problem is that
black has a made threat on G2 which
doesn't allow us to pick up the Rook on
d8 so I'll show this all after the game
right now we're low on time so we need
to focus on the matter at hand
so I'm fully expecting FG okay now it's
important to be tactically disciplined
we start by playing Queen takes G5 check
and Knight F6 is a blunder and this is
or is it a whoa whoa maybe it's not a
blunder
oh my God does he have Rook G8
oh my gosh I think I blundered
that is insane
oh man okay well I have to take I still
think white might be winning here though
oh my gosh he's got Rook G8 in this
position
that is unfreaking believable but I
think
that the position remains very
complicated even after
we lose our Queen which is what is going
to happen I feel like our opponent
missed Rook takes d8
and now gets lucky with Rook G8 we have
to sack Our Queen because if we move our
Queen we get checkmated on G2
how do we get the most amount of
material for our Queen we might very
well lose this game now we play Queen
takes G8 leading to a fascinating
position two Rooks for a queen and a
bishop which is generally a decisive
material advantage for the side of the
queen but the one caveat here is the
presence of this Pawn on A6 which is
what we started everything with we have
to go after this Pawn ASAP which means
we need to play Rook B8 and get this
Rook over to the seventh Rank and take
on A7 try to move the rook and basically
we're praying at this point I'm totally
praying a black will not be able to whip
up chances against our King in the time
that I take to win this pawn and move
the Rook back and push our a pawn what's
really helping white here is the fact
that Black's minor pieces are in
terrible shape and it's going to take
like a solid two or three Tempe until
black actually gets those pieces moving
again
and I feel like we might have just
enough time to orchestrate counter play
I think white is lost here objectively
I'll be totally honest and I completely
overlooked Rook G8 I completely
overlooked Rook G8 but we gotta bounce
back and recover
now things are are very interesting this
is definitely the closest I've been
barring the games that I've played
cheaters this guy's obviously legit this
is the closest that we are to losing a
speedrun game
obviously eventually I'll lose the
speedrun game I cannot win a thousand
out of a thousand games but this might
not be the one because I really feel
like practically we have great chin
there we go right the pressure is so
immense our opponent's nervous and
immediately he blunters the bishop and
this should do it
I really played that up and then the
moment I said all those things the
bishop is blundered right away
now I'm actually fascinated by the
computer evaluation here I'm curious of
why it's actually better in this
position yeah White's not worse
so it's equal with an only move no white
is winning I'm gonna check this on
stockfish 15. now I'm gonna check this
on stockfish 15. according to the
stockfish on chess.com white is still
winning here
let's check the actual eval
and that's actually what we're going to
start with and then we're going to dial
it back from there
well it's because of Rook B7 it's
because of Rook B7 and Rook takes A7
that pawn
ultimately wins us the game which is so
funny because that's that's what we
started with we started by getting the
pawn to A6 in the hopes that eventually
our investment would be rewarded and it
would so it was
and so it was okay so let me paste this
game into chess base
and I'm going to run stockfish 15 my
computer's gonna protest
all right here we go
so the evaluation after Rogue B8 is
it is completely winning for white it's
plus five
it is plus five for white in this
position Queen to A4 is the only chance
for black getting the queen behind the
pawn
now white plays Rook B7 check
ing F6 and Rook takes A7 and after black
gets the night out I mean black just has
no other way to get the minor pieces out
we simply play Rook A8
attacking the bishop and if the bishop
moves you play ace oh and this is
beautiful
this is beautiful and after King F7
there's one more hurdle that white has
to cross see the problem is you can't
move the Rook away because you give up
A7 but you can't move the Knight because
you blunder The Rook with Checkmate but
there is a very pretty idea that allows
white to circumvent these problems who
can spot the decisive tactics here it's
pretty simple it's Knight to C2 you sack
the Knight then you calmly move the Rook
to B8 black tries to generate counter
play but not fast enough we could even
just move the Rook away we don't we're
not even rushing to promote promoting
also works but so does Rook up one
Whatever Bishop B5 we promote on the
next move and we reach a technically
winning position or white is up
obviously a full exchange so just
incredible illustration of the power of
past pawns and the importance of active
pieces
the importance of active pieces so it
turns out if we rewind a little bit
I'm curious if C4 was actually the top
engine move it was
C4 was the best move and it was based on
a blunder
but I just got incredibly lucky C4 is
the best move the only move that wins
clearly
FG Queen G5 Knight F6 Rook d8 yep take
stakes and Rook B8 and white is winning
wow okay so
with that in mind I got incredibly lucky
it's like that joke about GM's throwing
the pieces up and it lands on the right
Square that's kind of what this reminds
me of
crazy crazy let's go back to the start
because there's a lot of theory to
unpack this is the opening Theory Speed
Run and the hope is that by watching
these games you will essentially be able
to play the elephant just on the basis
of the speedrun so Knight F6 E5 Knight
T5 I'm not gonna delve too deeply into
the theory of the traditional main line
which is D4 CD Knight F3 this is in fact
what the elephant Bible recommends
that's squeezing the Sicilian by
kalaflon and salavio they recommend the
traditional Mainline CD D6 Bishop C4 and
here the traditional main line goes
Knight B6 Bishop B5 you might be
familiar with the slide sorry D5 is a
move but d e and Bishop D7 is the main
line this has been very well known for
decades now it's an iqp structure
isolated Queen Pawn white has the bishop
pair but black essentially has control
of the square in front of the pawn these
two factors largely counterbalance each
other the position is equal but if black
opts for are the most popular move which
is Bishop B7 and black is slightly worse
after Queen G4 see it's the same idea
applied in a different position black
castles here generally white by takes on
C6 black takes with the pawn most of the
time Bishop H6 Bishop F6 and Rook F to
D1 and there's hundreds and hundreds of
games from this position white aims for
E4 with the Knight but recently a couple
of new moves have been introduced in
particular the move Rook d8 is the
choice of a lot of top GMS and it
basically takes this line out of
commission unfortunately Rook d8
completely equalizes because it puts a
lot of pressure on this Pawn right away
White Castles here most of the time but
ultimately after E6 you're gonna have to
protect this Pawn with this very passive
move then black plays Bishop E7 and if
you play Queen G4 now well here black
and castle and you've already wasted a
Tempo on one developing move Bishop H6
will make a lot less sense so long story
short the traditional main line is good
to know but I think there's a lot more
meat on the bone in the new Knight F3
and immediate Bishop C4 line so after
Knight B6 Bishop to B3 there's a fork in
the road and there's two moves that are
much more popular than the rest of
course D6 is going to transpose after
Pawn takes D6 the first move is what our
opponent played the second move is the
immediate C4 followed by Queen to C7
immediately trying to exploit the
weakness of the E5 Pawn this is why C4
is such a scary looking move because if
you say well no problem let me just
defend D5 no Black's gonna onpassant it
and you're gonna end up losing the
center Pawn but the crazy thing is that
the new way of approaching this position
is just to sacrifice the pawn just to
give it away you Castle here
black takes on E5 and this position
believe it or not is much better for
White And as far as I remember I'm going
to double check this yeah so the move
here is actually again A4
and A4 looks laughably innocuous here
and you might say well let's say that
black grabs control the center with D5
already white is almost winning you
throw in the Mover key one right now is
the time let's say black brings the
queen back to D6 now you play the move
Knights A3
so you're threatening to jump into B5
with Tempo so let's say black plays the
obvious A6 now we blast open the center
with D3
and after the trade the
problem for black is his lack of
development black just is a very very
hard time getting the bishop out of f8
and if he doesn't get the bishop out of
f8 then the king is not tucked away to
where it needs to go
if black plays G6 then white wins with
the move Queen to D4 attacking The Rook
black has to play this move and this is
already completely winning for white A5
forces the Knight back and now there's a
beautiful move exploiting the X-ray
against White's King there's this move
if black takes then he drops the queen
because you can't recapture if the queen
moves then the Knight Maneuvers back to
E3 this is plus five because black can't
defend the D5 Pawn E6 doesn't help white
takes anyway and Black's position
collapses
so G6 is too slow what about E6 turns
out E6 doesn't solve Black's problems
either in this position although it's
better than G6 here white calmly
develops the bishop to E3
it seems like black is already knocking
on the door but the secondary problem
this is why we've built the bishop Queen
battery but I can't Castle still because
of the Checkmate on H7 and this is an
unsolvable problem because it's not like
black and play G6
and if black plays an ugly move such as
F6 again white strikes with A5 brings
The Rook into the center and just look
at Black's position total and utter
paralysis and again black and never
Castle
and if E5 then no problem drop the
bishop back and D5 is now incredibly
tender this is plus two
so this position after A4 is
ridiculously dangerous for black and
understanding this fully is important if
you want to play this line successfully
so what other sample lines could I show
well what about the move A5 what if
black just says okay I get it I don't
want to allow you to push your Pawn to
A5 well now the B5 square is incredibly
weak you already know how to exploit
that the move is Knight A3 or you can
start with rookie one it doesn't matter
let's say black plays E6 that's the only
feasible move the Knight immediately
gets to B5
and if black develops the bishop again
it's the same Technique we play D3
and the point of D3 is not only to open
up the center it's also to prevent black
from castling notice that if black
castles immediately white can play DC
and after Knight takes C4 white of
course has Queen D3 which is winning
also winning is to start with rookie one
and if Queen C5 then white just tosses
black around and of course Bishop Bishop
A3 ends the game Bishop E3 Black's
position is in complete and total
shambles according to the engine Bishop
E4 is the best move apparently with the
idea of setting up Bishop A3 you're
waiting for black to go D5 and now you
play Bishop A3 the reason is that Bishop
A3 immediately black and drop the queen
over to G5 and he's still kicking so you
set up with Bishop B4 you're threatening
Bishop to E3 because you're taking away
the C6 Square from Black's Queen right
Bishop E3 immediately black is still
holding on with Queen C6 it should be
four is just classic computer chess
and black is totally busted
so that doesn't work either giving up
the B5 square is suicidal which means
nobody's gonna play A5 here but if you
don't play A5 we already looked at D5
there's also E6
there's also E6 but largely the the
tenor of the position remains unchanged
you can start with rookie one I think
this is actually the main line and this
is the Lesser evil for black but again
you play the move D3 Again by opening up
the center you're making it virtually
impossible for black to complete their
development
according to the engine white is much
better Bishop B7 and again 90 Knight A3
and if black plays A6 then you push A5
you centralize the Knight and you get
this massive clamp on Black's position
which over compensates for the
sacrificed pawn something like D6 you
could play Queen D4
encouraging black to Castle but now the
bishop comes into the center and you
just have complete and total domination
over all three sides of the board which
is the theme of this game
so if black plays
Knight back to F6 then we stick the
Knight right in Black's Grill
then we can move our Bishop back and
this sort of resembles the Smith Mora
type compensation where you just have
domination in terms of your piece
placement and black just doesn't have
any way to untangle so something like
this is I think the main line and
everywhere white is objectively and
practically much better and so this is
what makes this line so exciting it's
basically busted Knight takes E5
and it basically tells us that Queen C7
which traditionally was considered the
line that everybody used to play White
played Queen E2 automatically this was
what people played and then a couple
years ago castles became all the rage
and it virtually refutes the line with
C4 unless black plays D6 which is a
whole different line this is something I
won't talk about as much right now just
in the interest of time here it's a very
similar idea you trade and castle and
you quickly play A4 and try to run this
Pawn up the board I'll leave the
analysis of this position to our next
alopin game for now let's address D5
because there's a lot to talk about here
as well castles black and play C4 here
and transpose into the position that we
just had instead our opponent goes for
the main line Bishop E6 so here again
after the trade
10 15 years ago everybody used to play
D4 this was considered mandatory and
this line was analyzed to exhaustion you
get this trade on D4 and black has
actually I think several ways to
equalize the simplest is of course to
play Rook d8 and there are some crazy
lines here this is very very theoretical
the queen gets into E2 but engines have
completely exhausted this line and black
is fine here according to the engines
black is fine black is equal so the move
A4 has breathed so much new life into
this allopin variation and our opponent
continues correctly with Queen D7 we
push A5 we shove this Pawn all the way
down to A6 again B6 is largely forced
and now we push D4 so here there is
again a fork in the road
C takes D4 is the most common move and
after Knight takes D4 if black
nonchalantly trades then black is
already worse because it's almost
impossible to get the bishop out of f8
okay and you might say well what about a
move like Knight F6 trying to trade
Queens well white is happily going to
trade Queens here why because of the
weakness of the A7 Pawn now the Knight
has a ready-made Pathway to B5 and if
black tries to prevent the knight from
reaching B5 it's going to move on to C4
and now it's threatening Knight E5 check
Black's King is actually in Mortal
danger here if King to D5 the Knight
drops back into the center
or yeah let's say this move and now Rook
D1
and after E6 the Knight moves right back
to C4 and again 95 is virtually
Unstoppable so it's the combination of
flex lack of kingside development
coupled with the weakness of the plot on
A7 that makes this end game really
really bad for black
and if black plays E6 well now White's
not in a hurry and we can work on our
development either with Knight A3 or
with the move Rook D1 again the bishop
can't come out and black doesn't have
any easy ways to solve that problem
okay
hopefully this makes sense so our
opponent plays a good move E6 is
considered I think the best that black
can do although maybe the more accurate
move order is to take first and then
places this actually might be the way
the black wants to play this the
downside of playing it like this is that
white gets now an additional resource
who can tell me what additional resource
white gets in this position that we
didn't have here here we have of course
the move 95 but in this version white
has a sort of equivalently annoying move
what am I talking about
it's it's Knight B5 it's the move Knight
B5 which is kind of a major theme of
this entire game is trying to get this
Knight and ensconceit onto B5
and this Knight is pressuring A7
the theory goes on here you might have
to check this with the engine yourself I
don't want to get too bogged down in the
details here I'm probably already boring
you as it is but I'm pretty sure the
Knight B5 is considered to be a small
Advantage for white and so our
opponent's choice to not allow that is
understandable but this is incredibly
unpleasant for black from a practical
standpoint this position is I think I
don't want to say unplayable but it's
it's I think it's really really bad
so our opponent plays rook d8 and we
work on our development with Knight A3 a
lot of you were concerned about the
appearance of the move B5 and remember
this Knight is completely chilling it's
got tremendous potential energy and On
Demand any time that we feel like we
want to involve this Knight more
directly in the game who can tell me how
we can force this Knight how we can
break through the Shrubbery on the queen
side if we want to we don't have to do
that now but on demand we can play the
move C4 and the Knight is feeling
amazing on C4 it's chilling it's
threatening potentially to jump into D6
and again anytime black plays Bishop E7
we respond with Queen G4 and before you
know it black is completely and utterly
paralyzed uh in a way like this okay so
B5 is not scary but we don't even have
to play C4 we could still play the move
Queen G4 and keep C4 in our back pocket
for a rainy day B4 is not dangerous in
fact it merely encourages the Knight to
get to C4 and if black tries C4 well
then black weakens the D4 square and the
Knight can take another route to get to
this very nice Outpost in the center
okay so don't be afraid of moves that
stop your ideas because oftentimes they
create further weaknesses in your
opponent's Camp also understand that yes
the knights on the rim and yes it might
not be controlling any squares right now
but it's causing tremendous strain on
Black's position and that was The
Narrative of this entire game Bishop E7
I think is a serious mistake according
to the engine Knight to C7 was the only
way to preserve a feasible position but
even here I think that white is
significantly better after Queen G4 and
here the sacrifice is Justified because
our pieces get into the game so quickly
watch this bishop G5 if Bishop E7 then
we could even take and queen A4 forking
the knight in the king
and if King takes C7 then Rook D1 is
winning and if black moves The Rook well
then Rook fd1 I think is game over and
our Knight comes in the a file is open
so the A6 font is amazing right it's
such a strong Pawn because if it's
captured then the a file opens and
that's in our favor if it's not captured
then we capture the pawn on A7 and the
pawn promotes that's why there's so much
hype around this move A4 okay
so Bishop B7 Queen G4 here our opponent
kind of panics I think king f8 would
have been the best defensive resource
here for black again castles Bishop H6
illustrates the power of this pawn
bishop F6 is the move black wants to
play but can't so black has to drop the
exchange the other move that black would
like to play is G6 but it allows us to
stick the bishop right in Black's Grill
and prevent black from Castle in
kingside also very bad so I understand
why our opponent played Bishop f8 but
this just undevelops his pieces and now
I think black is just lost
plus it it encourages us to play Bishop
G5 with Tempo so I think king of f8 is
what I would have played with black and
we would have probably responded with
Rook to D1
and now we're threatening to play C4
according to the computer black is
supposed to play B5 here which of which
we respond with C4 and it's like plus
one right we just have domination on all
sides of the board this is good stuff
so in any case
Bishop f8 Rook D1
and the Tactical subtlety that I had to
foresee is that Knight F6 is a
nice looking move because it forces the
queen trade but this is where the power
of the Pawn on A6 is fully revealed
actually we don't even need to rush with
this move we could first bring the
bishop out to F4 to protect D5 that's
such a patient move and you might say
but doesn't this give black a chance to
rush the king over to B8 well yeah but
Rook D1 ends the game because this is a
made threat after Bishop E7 we go Rook
D7 rook d8 and Rook B7 is made into
beautiful otherwise by the way the Rooks
would have been forced off the board if
we didn't have this operation or
symmetrically Knight takes A7
so it's a nice mixture of positional and
tactical ideas in this game Queen C6 is
what our opponent did now we bring our
Bishop into the game
it turns out that F6 hasten's black
demise but in response to Rook C8 we
would have definitely played the move C4
and gotten the Knight to B5 and you can
figure this out yourself this is
completely and totally winning I think
the simplest plan in a position like
this is just to double Rooks on the D
file which you can do even after H5
although this is unnecessary and you
could just move your queen to the side
black is no moves black is completely
and utterly paralyzed and even if he
takes on A6 we've now transitioned our
attention to the D file and Rook d8 is
totally Unstoppable Bishop E7 oh we grab
we grab and queen F6 is going to be made
these lines are pretty one-sided what's
up wanked my opponent in the chat
yeah yeah he says I hated the A6 spawn
the second it arrived there no that pawn
is the bane of your existence so F6 is
understandable and great job finding
that Rook G8 resource it's basically
pure luck turns out the C4 is the best
move
and the reason I didn't drop the bishop
back is because of Knight F4
and I was very tempted by this move
and this position looks winning for
white but it's actually winning for
black after King F5
because black is threatening mate and G4
check the king tucks away on G6 and here
white can simply resign because of the
threat of checkmates you have to be
careful Until the End don't fall in love
with these tactical ideas you have to
calculate them and just because your
king is safer it doesn't mean that the
complications are always going to work
out in your favor that's why I played C4
of course I was expecting King Y8 and
here I think Knight B5 is incredibly
strong much stronger than taking the
Knight on D5 because the Knight isn't
going anywhere it can move to C7
technically it can move to E7 I think
the simplest approach here is actually
well actually Rook D1 check wins the
queen because King C8 Knight A7 is a
fork and here there's Knight D6 followed
by Knight F7 and Knight takes h8 another
great illustration of not getting
fixated on Checkmate rather you just win
a decisive amount of material and
there's nothing left to calculate okay
so don't spend your remaining time for
oh can I somehow use the discount no
just forget about Knight F7 Knight h8
the game is over there's nothing left to
calculate
so no matter how you slice it either
white takes on A7 and Retreat retracts
the Knight and then promotes or we win
on the D file there's just too many
areas of the board where black is
suffering perhaps Bishop E7 is the
Lesser evil but we always have this
check and the simplest is just to take
on A7 and get this Knight back to B5
this is the simplest way to win followed
by A7 and Knight C7
um and I was definitely you know
doubting myself at some points it's
crazy that Rook G8 wins the queen but we
have this magical resource Queen takes
G8 and Rogue B8 and there's just nothing
that black can do against the threat of
Rook B7 that's actually what we started
with we went full circle so don't feel
too bad wank that you gave up this
bishop your position was lost amazingly
because there's just no stopping this
plan the pawn on A6 decides the game
and you know great job for not sort of
automatically grabbing The Rook which I
think a lot of people would have done
this loses The Rook on h8 and loses the
game you paused here and said wait a
second my king is amazingly safe but I
managed to maintain my composure and
find Rook V8 ultimately just your minor
pieces are too passive and your queen
isn't able to stop the pawn on its own
okay guys
so thank you all
foreign
[Music]